cet homme a décidé de prendre tous les
risques
tous les samedis soirs il va relever un
formidable défi vous tenir en haleine
pendant une heure pour vous empêcher de
zapper et conserver son hardy matt il
est prêt à tout moyens sont bons même la
qualité
[Musique]
1 tous les avis sont unanimes y avait du
bon et du moins bon marquez avait quand
même plus de moi un bond de bon hein
enfin tout le monde est d'accord à la
télévision pour se faire une idée faut
attendre la deuxième ou la troisième
quand même la quatrième ou la cinquième
des fois la sixième ou la septième
fournier devra également rappelé les
ambitions de cette émission
ce sont celles du service public faire
de la qualité sans oublier l'audience
sans négliger la qualité tout en faisant
de l'audience c'est très clair n'est ce
pas
d'autre part de nombreux téléspectateurs
ont été choqués par le sort réservé à
asa notre petit chien dans le cas où
leur dit matt descendre en dessous de
15%
je tiens à leur rappeler qu'à la
télévision tous les moyens sont bons
pour arriver d'autres téléspectateurs
n'y croit pas et pensent qu'il s'agit
d'un gag c'est mal me connaître
c'est oublier que si vous zappez je suis
d'accord alors ma gauche toujours irène
et jean pierre bonsoir bonsoir thierry
l'autre content d'être revenu en
deuxième semaine
ah bah oui on aime ça on est très
content c'est vrai pour nous ça nous
fait une sortie enfin bon c'est surtout
pour vous parce que on a vu quand même
les résultats de la semaine dernière la
personne qui nous a montré les ce qu'est
ce qui a marché ce cas pas marcher bombe
à cesser c'est exactement ce qu'on vous
a bein oui oui et contre servette la
main quand vous a dit ça on aime bien
aimée avec téléspectateurs ils ont aimé
aussi et puis quand on vous a dit ça
sentait moins c'est plus tard on dit
pareil ça prouve bien qu avec ma femme
on est pile dans
la sensibilité du public donc si vous
avez envie que ça marche il faut nous
écoute et on viendrait peut-être un
troisième soldat captif
je crois que le dispositif était au
point un oui l'animateur entre le
marteau de la direction et l'enclume les
téléspectateurs je reconnais vraiment
épuisé puisque nos téléspectateurs
moyens parler des résultats de la
semaine dernière on et faire un petit
bilan avec un premier constat de la
séquence qui a le mieux marché la
semaine dernière c'est le clip de
michael jackson vous aviez programmé
avec un résultat formidable notamment
sur les 15 17 ans en bretagne et sur les
13 21 ans dans le roussillon et là je
dois rendre hommage à votre flair et aux
grands professionnels vraiment michael
jackson il fallait y penser j'en suis
comme deux ronds de flan vous avez oui
enfin c'est pas si difficile là vous
mettez le doigt sur le secret des grands
programmateur de télévision les
qu'ancien les brière les gens qui
connaissent très bien leur métier moi
c'est tout ça que j'avais remarqué que
michael jackson avait vendu à peu près
450 millions d'albums qu'il était
deuxième au top 50 et un soir j'étais au
restaurant avec ma femme et je lui ai
dit michael jackson on va programmer
naiken jackson et ça a marché formidable
et à quoi ça tient quand même ce qui
s'appelle et xla ce qui s'appelle avoir
vraiment du pif et à cet égard j'ai une
surprise pour vous un des vétérans du
paf haras vous décerner la médaille de
grand pif du bafa pour récompenser être
cet exploit n'ayant pas eu de sept d'or
j'en suis ravie professeur avait un 7
d'or c'est pas grand chose un grand pif
du paf c'est
avec la salle
dre plaisir
parce que nous à moi c'est la télévision
de a jusqu'à z
et oui ce n'est pas seulement celui là
ce très minces ardisson thierry wident
de nice alpes maritimes
oui j'ai l'honneur de vous remettre au
nom du peuple français
oui le pif du paf merci aura bonne idée
que vous avez eue la semaine dernière
vous n'avez pas d'une grossièreté ce qui
est rare on n'avait pas fait un jeu de
mots vilain vous avez respecté ou à peu
près la langue française continue et
thierry et j'observe et la vie à un
jackson surtout merci les ondes ça me
touche beaucoup placé beaucoup
bravo
[Applaudissements]
l'eau
c'est michael jackson tels effet le
meilleur dit matt en troisième position
venait dracula vous auriez fait quoi ma
place jackson dracula brakina jackson le
mix des deux c'est twitter
le premier sujet mardi matin
[Musique]
arrêté
mais bodmer
[Musique]
k
c'est
[Musique]
pratiquer
non
m
nice et la corse
[Musique]
le frenchy
francophonie
mais tout le monde l'a
ce chiffre
[Musique]
non
oh
[Musique]
m
quelle santé
deux pas
voilà
allez
[Applaudissements]
enfin les années soixante dix coluche
enregistré un sketch consacré au
président de la république de l'époque
valéry giscard d'estaing
mais suite à la fameuse affaire boulin
ce sketch de coluche a été interdit et
il est resté inédit jusqu'à ce jour
ce sketch hardy matt la retrouver et
vous le découvrirez en exclusivité à la
fin de cette émission
pourquoi pas tout de suite vous me direz
parce que si je le diffuse tout de suite
vous risquez de ne pas rester jusqu'à la
fin de l'émission
et ça c'est pas possible n'est ce pas ap
fallait-il jean louis saez aujourd'hui
200 ans après seulement 9 % des français
condamnerait louis saez à la guillotine
53 % se prononcent pour l'exil 20% pour
l'emprisonnement 19 pour l'équipement
aujourd'hui 200 ans après une question
en ces historiens et si louis saez avait
été mal défendu pour engager le débat
sur les aléas de justice andi menthe
apporte une pièce déterminante dossier
voici m albert dupontel dans sa
plaidoirie
mon client comparaît aujourd'hui devant
la 2e chambre d'accusation pour viol
quoi de plus normal qu'une chambre pour
un viol
on va pas dramatiser il c'est fait c'est
fait qu'elle est là quelle est la
définition du viol
si l'on en croit le petit robert encore
qu'à son âge que peut-il savoir du viol
à
bon alors si vous êtes venus pour faire
la gueule faut le dire tout de suite
alors cesser l'utilisation de moyens
violents pour un rapport sexuel
si l'on en croit la rumeur populaire ô
combien plus juste c'est quand femmes
pas voulu marquer 4 alors je pose une
question dans cette affaire où est la
fin il n'y a pas de fin il n'y a que
deux adolescents de 40 et de 15o attirés
l'un par l'autre peut-être plus l'un que
l'autre c'est vrai n'est pas de femmes
la victime et l'accusé sont du même sexe
1 le tien et plus gros paquet l'horreur
à l'aide de faire de l'esprit parce que
c'est pas gagné au courage il était pas
encore acquittés ils sont très beaux
dessins jeu les verts après la victime
l'accusé sont du même sexe aux 10es ge
alors de quel procès s'agit-il ici de
celui de l'amour des hommes par d'autres
zones mais enfin mais qui sommes-nous
pour tourner le dos aux homosexuels
ils disent accrochant quoi
remontant à l'antiquité époque fertile
en amour stérile et si ton cas ton vieux
moi sectionner tous les sens comme une
planche à voile ou de l'homosexualité
c'est un peu comme la planche à voile il
suffit de s'y mettre
oh là là quelle chimiques etc etc
alors certes quoique fréquentes
l'homosexualité n'est pas obligatoire
non est ce une bonne chose la question
n'est pas là toujours est il que mon
client n'avait pas obligé la victime et
ça c'est très vrai alors qu'est ce qui
s'est passé entre les deux enfants
qu'elle joue anodin d attirer
l'internaute cache cache col à mayen la
marraine le skate bowl plus probablement
son mouton le fait que la victime
s'appelle moutons et que mon client est
un peu dur d'oreille certainement pas
étranger à la verse aux boutons sur le
bouton ce qui sort
olivier de kersauson dans les veines
éthylique dans les grosses têtes de
philippe bouvard ont fait oublier les
exploits maritime
olivier de kersauson donc a décidé de
faire le tour du monde en 80 jours
à l'heure où je vous parle prétextant
une mauvaise météo il n'a toujours pas
pris la mer il faut dire à sa décharge
que l'amiral comme le surnomment ses
amis a toujours eu beaucoup plus de
facilité pour vider les bouteilles que
pour les cas c'est un vrai problème le
baptême des bateaux comme le monde ce
document vivis
[Musique]
c'est un mégot jeté le corps l'esprit et
vous
[Musique]
toi
on
[Musique]
lancez vous
géré en interne
minimes des supports qui place of the
world turns alors oui c'est les neuf
[Musique]
faut-il ou non frapper des cibles
civiles le bombardement du levant lieu
de bagdad révèle des divergences
chez les alliés d'après le canard
enchaîné le président mitterrand
penseraient que les usa sont allés trop
loin
il faut dire que en 1984 le beau-frère
du président projet n avait réalisé un
film train d'enfer ou trois français
linge en arabe alors les ratonnades
électronique ou par mitterrand qui
peuvent aider
[Musique]
bah
dimaga à cacher un vainqueur
hu
à
il ya six mois
auj
ah ah
la mer
d'après
à
oui
demain
or cela
avant de quitter le 2 encore un mot sur
le koweït le qatar et les autres
monarchies pétrolières là-bas ce ne sont
pas les populations civiles qui
souffrent puisque le revenu par habitant
y est un des plus élevés du monde là-bas
ce sont les princes les émirs l'échec et
des pachas ton de gros problèmes chaque
fois qu'ils creusent un trou même pour
faire un goal ils trouvent du pétrole
écoutons jean constantin nous en parle
c'est un chat est un chat est un chat un
pacha père d'argent chats persans si
puissant que dans son que dans son jeu
dans ton son arène toutes les femmes lui
disait cha cha cha comme on t'aime mais
malgré ces mini c'est m'immiscer
milliards le pacha chercha avait bien le
cafard des ppp ppd pétrole il était
saturé car son rêve c'est d'avoir poussé
le cab
[Musique]
commençons par faire tant qu'elles sont
allées au coût de 16 ans mais chaque
fois qu'il retrait qu'ils creusaient des
trous trou par trou seront en tout l'aï
tout pour trouver 1 6 6 1 fifi filet
d'eau du pp du pétrole jaillit sceptre
aussitôt et les sous les soussous les
sourciers l'essentiel nous laisse des
mines
je suis aux prises avec l'ascension
militaire quelle va être la marge de
manoeuvre laissée aux journalistes
comment ont-ils vraiment le droit de
savoir
en orient
à une époque où à travers des affaires
comme la sphère botton on en apprend
plus sur la presse que la presse nous en
apprend pour regrette beaucoup le vrai
journalisme d'investigation celui de
pierre desproges par exemple comment ça
va le petit santé de balle très bien
merci
ça va très bien oui il allait bien oui
ça va très bien il n'y a pas de problème
non non allégé même commune tout-paris
millions qu'est ce que je veux dire
la robe est là
c'est pas mal quand issus à ces couacs
au stade louis ii de tétouan le fanal de
drap reste le jeu prend sa peluche passe
à eux non non ce sont tous un peu ce pas
ce tissu assez sec ça se lavent
commencent à se lave à l'eau tiède
secret club eh bien il ya de soutenir sa
savent plus tôt 70 des choses comme il
sait le tact nature y est ah bon ouais
ouais ouais on peut pas de toute façon
je n'ai pas le temps moi aussi quand je
n'ai pas le temps je donne des trucs
nous accueillons nature y est oui sinon
vous resterez toujours à faire des
lessives
c'est vrai qu'elle est et les vacances
c'était bien vos vacances vous étiez en
vacances chevaux ânes on l'achetait
panda quand ce travail et non mais avant
le rôle avant j'avais l'avantagé de
sécurité avant de travailler j'étais en
vacances en france
forcément oui oui c'était facile il a
fait très beau c'est du beau temps aussi
oui moi je sais je suis allé chercher
mon beau-frère que près de limoges
joaillier ah oui je connais moi c'était
de l'humour et sa bande ça descend c'est
le choix qui est 17e et les champignons
à l'eau ce moment en ce moment c'est
bien le champignon et je me suis bien
marré comment vous faire c'est d'ajouter
des photos
les zélateurs cd photos qu'on a fait
avec ajouté en vacances ou au beau frère
ça c'est moi la lance le chien l'a fait
pardon c'est un chien là c'est pas nous
c'est presque un chien là ah ouais c'est
mon chien ça à ma part de risques pour
ses un copain pendant vos frères c'est
en offrir
et il sympathique facile mais ça c'est
des copains qui jouent au boulier bombe
en farsi celui-là oui
puis lors su ça c'est un copain ou sa
cdd
copains qui passent enfin des copains je
connais un peu quand on est des petits
oui et puis ça c'est le nôtre copains et
ça c'est le frère de celui là eh ben je
ne sais pas ce que je peux faire pour
[Musique]
vous je vais pas vous faire quelque
chose je pense qu'il n'est pas petit
mutina way au oui c'est ça que je savais
pas qu à tout à l'heure je devais
demander j'ai pris ça j'en passe à
décider si je n'avais pas je vous
connaissais pas bien avant alors je
pourrai ça aussi on va rarement à cette
heure ci enfin ça je peux en trouver si
vous voulez julien qui demandaient des
mouillettes emile est des médiathèques
du pain pour tremper rapidement revenir
sur un petit point de bilan de la
semaine dernière d'abord il faut vous
dire que la séquence qui a le moins bien
marché et de très loin
c'est la séquence sur sarajevo et
l'archiduc trop intello ça a fait un
score minable trop service public on m'a
dit maintenant c'est possible qu'il soit
programmé cette merde c'est un de votre
but documentaliste c'est le nommé
bertrand bertrand bertrand à arriver
oui c'est vous qui avez programmé la
séquence sur sarajevo
oui c'est moi oui très bien bon vous
pouvez ranger vos affaires vous ne fait
plus partie de la maison
pourtant cette avance sur écoute et
verte et si vous discutez pas vous allez
encore nous faire perdre des points vous
êtes dur à l'est
yamaha
j'ai craqué
[Applaudissements]
je crois que
un nouveau personnage d'art dimaté mien
merci patron
c'est y faire avec ces bêtises il nous a
fait perdre 42 % des ouvriers et 57% des
professions libérales mais alors il ya
pire
et là c'est votre faute samedi dernier
vous avez employé le mot prémices au
masculin pluriel
alors qu'il est du féminin pluriel et si
vous ne me croyez pas regardez l'extrait
vous venez d'assister aux prémices de la
première guerre mondiale
passons maintenant à ceux de la deuxième
qui au temps pour moi
bah oui mais ça c'est très grave qui
rien parce que les jeux ne supporte pas
ce genre de fautes ils ont zappé
massivement on à perdre écouter regarder
la courbe là avant la faute fatidique
ici et ici paf prémices à l'essai
l'hémorragie ah oui les gens ne
supportent pas ce genre de fautes ils
ont écrit par milliers à la chaîne 1
pour dire qu'ils ne paieront plus la
redevance si c'est pour entendre des
analphabètes massacrer la langue
française
les gens nous demandaient vous soyez
immédiatement remplacé par julien lepers
bah oui mais thierry reconnaissait la
potins alors maintenant pour compenser
il va nous falloir diffusé quatre
secondes de documents naturel sur venise
et ses musées gérés la dignité du
service public est à ce prix il s'agit
de la dignité du service tout en la
voyant pas revenir au débouché du grand
canal
la salle haute et opéra baroque ciselé
dans la pierre blanche dresse sur le
pourtour de sa coupole tout un peuple de
statut vibrante comme les choristes d'un
p des hommes quand tous les cuivres de
l'orchestré qu'on a fait le jeu de la
qualité on pourrait maintenant penser un
petit peu l'art dit maintenant pourquoi
pas attirer je crois que j'ai une idée
laquelle grande idée une grande idée qui
justifie qu j'ai été décoré qui montre
bien que je suis de la trempe des dés qu
ancien des brières laquelle ferrer de
laquelle la présence féminine au non
achat prodigieux dans ladite comment est
ce que vous avez eu cette idée géniale
seraient venus comment mais vous avez un
pif ben j'étais au restaurant avec ma
femme c'est comme ça un petit peu
tu peux perdre vu comme ça et vous
mangiez quoi du coup trade d'agneau dans
un restaurant marié et alors et alors je
la regarde et d'un seul coup je me dis
une présence féminine g il manque une
présence féminine dans cette émission
gignac thiriez alors vous avez trouvé
quelqu'un j'ai quelqu'un sandrine
bonsoir ça voulait être présence
féminine chez new sandrine sa dépouille
ça dépend de quoi on va vous appeler
sans briller très original pour
commencer avec un c'est cendrillon a dit
sandrine et quel âge avez-vous fait
l'amour pour la première
non non non non non
tombé dans vos anciennes erreurs on va
encore avoir toute la presse sur le no
koi la presse après celle madore la
presse est là toujours été avec moi à la
presse je ne sais pas ce qu'il vous faut
regarder le témoignage de monsieur
fabrice pliskin gens des gens réalistes
josé nouvel observateur regardez les
défroquées de la réclame ancien el-ater
de la barre ovomaltine des biscottes
vasa et du chaussée aux moines syrie
ardisson se donne aujourd'hui pour le
roi du journalisme d'inquisition
cette variante cracra du journalisme
d'investigation
toutes les vérités sont bonnes à dire
aime à répéter le torquemada du show biz
surtout les vérités d'alcôve dans ses
interviews ardisson traque l'info
vaginale et l'intox clitoridienne albert
londres du point g
saadé ontologie se résume en quatre mots
par devant par derrière dans un langage
énergique
on pourrait dire qu'on va chez lui comme
on va à confesse ardisson et le
psychanalyste des stars le lac en du
cancan le seul homme en france à être
obsédé par la vie sexuelle de dorothée
ce pervers polymorphe de l'audimat
semble confondre service public et
sévices publics et comme l'auto
flagellation et la forme supérieure de
l'autocélébration il soudoie des
journalistes de faire pour venir
l'écorché dans sa propre émission double
jeu d'un éternel provincial saisi par la
débauche du parisianisme
oui effectivement on peut dire ça mais
enfin c'est même pas mal écrit c'est
formidable il avait la raison oui tu as
raison je dirais pas ça mais après tout
tout le monde à tout le monde a sa
petite
dechavanne à sophie favier de cauna
agnès boulard annie pujol enfin pourquoi
je n'aurai pas ma petit moi c'est pas
faut peut-être demandé aux
téléspectateurs français jean-pierre que
c'est une bonne idée un soin
oui c'est vrai ça apporte une note de
fraîcheur de gaieté quoi c'est bien moi
je trouve que voilà un bon professeur
oui bon on va écouter thierry d'accord
maintenant il ya un seul problème il
faut qu'elle fasse quelque chose pour
vous composer si elle ne fait rien les
téléspectateurs ne sont pas fous ils
verront bien qu'elle est là pour faire
potiche va exciter les retraités alors
il faut qu'elle fasse quelque chose il
faut lui donner un rôle il faut qu'elle
ait une fonction
sandrine et des diplômes quoi physique
très bien alors les chiffres ne vous
font pas peur madame dans ces conditions
quelle nous donnerait pas la température
qu'il fait dans ce studio parce que
c'est vrai on se dit tout le temps dit
on se dit fait chaud mais combien show
tirait on ne sait pas ce qu'il fait 21
moi je vois qu'elle pourrait nous donner
à tout moment l'état de la température
ici la fonderie c'est pas le choix non
tu sais la télé c'est ça il faut savoir
commencer en bas tu veux y arriver il
faut commencer en bas et bien
physiquement je commencerai par le
barbant il faut que tu as changé c'est à
dire qu'il faut que tu t'habilles d'une
façon un petit peu plus sexy prend
exemple sur les autres petits jeux la
télévision si j'avais su qu'un jour je
finirai potiche à la télévision le toit
de me prouver le contraire ma petite
sandrine la semaine dernière le football
est arrivée en deuxième position
derrière michael
vous avez apprécié de revoir
l'affrontement battiston schumacher je
m'étais dit un truc qui avait intéressé
2 milliards de téléspectateurs ne
pouvait pas être un mauvais choix
c'est aussi pour ce genre d'idée monde
le groupe eavs du pape cette semaine on
va rester dans le sport avec l'arrivée
du marathon des jeux olympiques de los
angeles en 84 attention je répète ce que
vous allez voir ce n'est pas l'arrivée
dans le 100 mètres d'une coursed
handicapés mais bien l'arrivée d'un
marathon normal on regarde
la grèce n'avait jamais été si paris los
angeles un flashback de 25 siècles
titubant de droite à gauche sur les 400
derniers mètres du stade olympique
gabriel là malgré sa combinaison ultra
moderne mais du cap canaveral gabriella
nous renvoie tout droit au célèbre
message est venu apporter en courant aux
athéniens la nouvelle d'une victoire sur
les perses en lan 490 avant jésus-christ
tout le monde a oublié cette bataille
mais non pas l'exploit du coureur
c'était un marathon bien sûr un petit
village de l'attique
[Applaudissements]
on se dépêche
je déteste avons à décembre je suis très
inquiet pour simple choses n'ont pas de
sexe problème du service public c'est
que c'est plus facile de parler de la
consommation des glaces en angleterre
que de cul oui bon d'accord
maintenant on voit moins les glaces aux
quêtes ou tel crime
[Applaudissements]
pas mal
alors pour conclure qu à la télévision
bob bell en cas enquêtés bornou être le
sexe à la télévision pour pour oui
pourquoi parce que ça me paraît faire
partie d'une nouvelle réalisation qui
est absolument nécessaire et je trouve
qu'aujourd'hui justement on a peur de
tout alors je suis en 2 x pour non je
suis contre parce que ces têtes raides
sont vulgaires et je trouve qu'il ya
quelque chose de très dangereux c'est de
banaliser des choses qui sont aussi
importantes dans la vie des individus
non je dis non je suis anti sexe je ne
suis pas pour ce genre de chose qui est
purement de paix ce talent je suis pas
ça ne dérange pas vous regarder
ouais ça vous excite temps en temps vous
regardez seul ou avec quelqu'un à mon
copain et se débouche sur quelque chose
l'amour
pourquoi je reviens je sais pas ça me
fait bander peut-être un petit peu
est ce que vous regardez des films
pornographiques oui ça arrive ça vous
plaît qu'est ce qui vous plaît dans le
team porno quel genre de scènes un peu
près vous regardez sa seule ou avec
quelqu'un allait quelqu'un et ça se
passe comment généralement ça se passe
bien et ça débouche sur quoi ça doit à
gauche et c'est à dire on a préféré la
pornographie bien dur
en belgique je suis la belgique c'est du
pur et dur asseman quels sont vos scènes
préférées
je sais pas j'aime bien un peu de
l'algérie d'où tout seul vous touchez un
petit peu en regardant les films
pornographiques non du tout ça vous fait
rien ça c'est bondé quand même qu'est ce
qui vous plaît on sait que c'est bon
c'est certain on voit ça vous fait
quelque chose
6h et raison oui moi chez les femmes
ça vous choque un peu non pas mes amants
quand vous regardez la télévision c'est
sexy si vous êtes avec un homme ne se
passe rien non et s'il entreprend
quelque chose peut-être peut-être
qu'est ce qui vous plaît dans le sexe et
la télévision ça fait une petite
variante ça s'amuse ça crée un
divertissement que ça vous distrait oh
oui bien sûr ça vous rappelle des
souvenirs
on prend particulièrement enfin sur la
genèse de l'armée et les films
pornographiques ça vous plaît ça ne me
déplaît pas ça vous excite
ça dépend desquels en général ce qui
passe à la télé télévison
c'est très léger donc non pas cela ne
vous préférez des foulards puis là mais
ceux là on les voit pas la télévision
vous croyez que tous les vieux cochons
qu'ils aient regardé c'était pour faire
pareil dans leur salon dimanche matin la
gymnastique c'est un bon moyen de
montrer des dents est sur le service
public
et comme jane fonda ne plaît plus bander
que le patron de cnn
on a choisi cindy crawford le mannequin
le mieux payé du monde
gratuit
[Musique]
la même flexion se bécoter alors sur le
côté et on remonte ça aussi c'est bon
pour la taille
[Musique]
on fait des blancs certes
frans
à
[Musique]
ouais et dans l'autre sens
[Applaudissements]
ok ferait toujours bien respirer
sans l'aide de simples avec les anges ça
fait du bien mais avait les jambes bien
droit et tout sur tout le bassin comme
ça
[Applaudissements]
à l'arrêt dans l'autre sens
écarté bien les gens qui donnent et
chauffée gentil
il faut aussi dans les criées après
avoir fait plaisir aux vilains messieurs
on a ce cube et les blanches colombes
blanches colombes et vilains messieurs
c'est le titre français de guys and
dolls un film de manquer vince tourné en
55 avec marlon brando qu'on manque
évident proposa le rôle à brando
celui ci refuse en disant qu'il n'avait
jamais fait de comédie musicale
mankiewicz le rappela en lui disant
rassure toi moi non plus rassurez vous
je ne vois pas du tout
[Musique]
je
non
[Musique]
il
bike
non pas les frais
[Applaudissements]
salut ais je vais avoir tiré gars disent
on sait pourquoi
voilà je suis père perret chanteur tu
vas pas reconnu je vais pas demander qui
vous êtes vous demandé c'est pourquoi
c'est parce que je viens faire un coup
de promo pour le casino de paris à qui
passe à partir du 26 janvier
c'est mardi que je démarre je vais faire
un coup de promo il n'y a pas de promo
hardy matt provost mais juste un petit
coup de promo comme ça vite fait sur le
gaz quoi c'est pour dire tiens intérêts
casino mais je viens de dire là il n'y a
pas de promo hardy matt oui c'est pas
clair il faut que je dise
autrement vous êtes boucher ou quoi pas
de remords écoute mon petit gars c'est
pas la peine de faire mousser le pied de
veau ou je suis pierre perret le
chanteur pacifique
je suis quand même le seul bien de tout
show biz à réussir la blanquette sens
qu'elle attache
écoutez pierre ferret paul père et
blanquette de veau bourguignon ici pas
de promo c'est clair non attends je le
connais personnellement ardisson mais le
cousin de la concierge de christine
bravo me l'a présenté il ya trois jours
dans une boîte branchée et est bon alors
il s'est passé des trucs dpu ces paris
sont ouverts de l'audience non mais j'ai
du mal à en faire seul pour lui tout
seul reste juste à temps
justement si notre promo mais moi je
venais pour lui filer un coup de palus
justement pour les bains le sétois qui
veulent prendre ça continue à nous mais
bon si vous le prenez comme ça alors
ja oui nous enquiquiner avec une promo
casino de paris pour le 24 janvier lors
26 à l'étoile avant oui ça lui est super
et bah oui bah moi je venais de voir
parce que justement pour la promo j'ai
vu de la lumière je les tiens on m'a dit
c'est le studio de 2,2 alors bon un coup
de promo en bas ça fait pas de mal c'est
bien vrai à la cible le voit non
pourquoi c'est pas beau c'est impossible
parce que nous on a déjà pas tellement
d'audience tu vois si en plus on tend
filon médusant de carbo fumier dans ton
genre toi aussi
ces matières [__] il y en a plein en a
à peine son ancienne belle saloperie a
pas toi avez qu'est ce que ça veut dire
ça fait pas chier mais bien une
pourriture cellule active et quant à
benoît des artistes mais je te rends
changer de branche vie des gens fait par
john macdougall de cloportes dégoulinant
[Musique]
non mais si c'est à la confession
l'énergie achetée 5000 $ les aveux de
l'assassin de john lennon vous n'avez
pas regardé que vous infligez la
punition parce que ma mère j'ai acheté
cinq mille dollars
les aveux non la semaine dernière j'ai
acheté cinq mille dollars
les aveux de saint john et n'admet pas
que la punition
la semaine dernière j'ai acheté 5000 $
les aveux de l'assassin de john lennon
vous n'avez pas regardé je vais vous
infligez la punition le gagnant le voici
guy ça va
[Applaudissements]
et grâce au parcours des deux fois plus
d'applaudissements
c'est bien alors comme vous avez 7 d'or
du son ça il faut parler au micro pour
les remerciements
oui mais c'est très difficile je
voudrais associer avec moi joël fort qui
a fait le mixage du film mon assistant
de l'époque qui était pascal podvin et
toute l'équipe surtout ainsi jean
chapeau qui a été le maître d'oeuvre de
2,7 de ce film et deviens d'autres merci
[Applaudissements]
d'un jour d'exposition botero sur les
champs elysées sera terminé et depuis
quelques semaines une étrange rumeur
parcourt les rédactions parisiennes du
sculpteur botero ne serait pas l'auteur
de ces sculptures
aujourd'hui cette rumeur se trouve
malheureusement vérifié par un document
filmé ces documents hardy matt vous le
présente en exclusivité
il démontre clairement que l'auteur des
sculptures faussement attribuée à botero
n'est autre qu'un certain jean marie
même but on regarde c'est bon on peut y
aller
[Musique]
gaffe je commence comme l'attestent
pour union sous l'eau rond
[Musique]
messieurs la connaissance des arts aura
coûté très cher aux services publics
ce document pourtant exceptionnel sur
botero a fait descendre larbi mac en
dessous de la ligne des 20 % à 15 the
tune chien présente page et de l'oise
alors soyez gentils rappeler vos proches
vos amis tous ceux qui viennent d'aller
stupidement se coucher et dites leur que
nous allons continuer à parler bugs et
sans connotation artistique d'accord
allez on passe tout de suite de l'art
noble aux nobles
[Musique]
m
puis une dame
non
mais
vous avez l'air songeur qui arriverait
je pense à mes fils je me dis qu'il ya
rien pour elle dans cette émission ça il
faut dire que déjà on n'intéresse pas
grand monde mais alors sur le créneau
des gosses c'est pire que tout mais rien
pour les mômes rien j'ai un truc
[Musique]
bon
iv
[Musique]
pas sûr
et
mais y aller
[Musique]
mais m
hier
m
alors ça vous a plu la la deuxième
émission il ya du bon et du moins bon
mais et la musique moi ça m'a plu
beaucoup
ah oui je suis content et en même temps
je trouve qu'ils ce qui manque dans
l'émission c'est des choses pour les
femmes à des des sujets sur la couture
les grands couturiers la mode les choses
comme ça moi ça me plairait bien
enfin moi franchement je vous le dis
ainsi sinon je regarde plus qua non non
par contre il ya vous avez vous avez une
trouvaille là avec sandrine vraiment les
biens
peut-être même qu'il faudrait qu'elles
reposent plusieurs fois avec d'autres
informations ou des normes effet de
serre pour vous
non mais c'est surtout des sujets dont
les femmes qu'il faudrait aussi parce
qu'en fait ça oui sign moi je trouve que
c'est à exploiter peut-être un créneau
et oui je suis sûr que très bientôt
comme sophie favier de coucou ou agnès
boulard de nulle part ailleurs sandrine
sera une énorme star quelles que soient
ses qualités d'ailleurs en warhol la vie
il ya longtemps dans l'avenir tout le
monde sera célèbre moins cinq minutes
prenez de maurice clavel pas qui se
souvient aujourd'hui que c'est
formidable
article du nouvel observateur qui se
souvient aujourd'hui des quatre essais
philosophiques qui l'a publié la seule
chose que l'on retient de lui c'est son
esclandre lors de l'émission armes
égales
le 13 décembre 1971 maurice clavel était
opposé à monsieur royer le débat portait
sur la 106 pour engager la discussion
non il se révèle avait réalisé un
document parce qu'il fut projeté il
remarqua qu'il avait été censurée
regarde que vient de prendre la décision
suivante je ne serai prendre part un
débat qui commence sous le régime de la
censure quels qu'en soient les victimes
waouh monsieur royer il soit bien
entendu monsieur royer je ne me dérobe
pas à une confrontation entre nous sur
le problème des moeurs et de la
culpabilité de la société je vous
propose de le reprendre sur n'importe
quelle chaîne de radio libre si on
existe et si évidemment vous renoncez à
la censure ben vous constatez ici le
désastre
quant au peuple français auquel je viens
très modestement de lancer un appel au
soulèvement de la vie contre ces espèces
de morts que sans la censure et autres
fascisme jose non - modestement lui
donner rendez-vous pour bientôt dans la
liberté pour la liberté
messieurs les censeurs bonsoir
le même émoi
à ces tests
mission je vous avais promis un sketch
il est dit de coluche je l'est pas j'ai
jamais eu mais grâce à cette promesse
certains d'entre vous ont peut être
garder jusqu'au bout
une émission qui l'aurait sans doute
quitter avant je sais c'est pas terrible
mais c'est ça la télé seule la fin
justifie les moyens
c'est dallas ouais d'accord mais
peut-être que comme ça j'ai réussi à
sauver sa peau
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
les corrections de ne rien rater de in a
l'habitude abonnez vous mettez un pouce
bleus